hello and welcome to this video playing
mobile creature and what is he doing for
$5.99 and he is going for Sicilian as
well yeah I play both lines he okay he
he knows his stuff
but surprised that he didn't take
wonderful so now I can take on c5 and
don't quite see how he gets it back so
easily
okay stay away for him to get it back
not yet so I can't play normal moose f5
he wants to prevent before but I can
also keep the pawn with the night Queen
to c7 okay not sure what he wants to do
here the knight c6 to h5 or something
okay let's develop
okay a most obvious is Queen d6 and just
forcing the trade and correcting my pawn
structure so not obvious how is going to
get it back so here yeah probably trade
once and this is a good square I am and
I'm threatening Bishop d7 okay here
looky five winsome materia but even sure
it was the best continuation but it
looks okay he resigned it's a it's a
pretty pretty bad position
okay let's let's have a look there
briefly so we had this and here black
shirt to capture this is no lucky take
Bishop c4 Queen d 8c takes I believe on
Knight eggs one night I think Knight
takes and I'm not entirely sure I think
black is quite okay here it's nothing
nothing terrible at same yeah Queen d8 I
think there is no compensation to be
honest this was just a pawn sorry if
I've tried to bread before but I was
stopping this pawn and this is even if
he gets it back it's a pretty favorable
Queen side pawn structure and he's not
getting it back I don't see how this
would work
Jie sixes I thought maybe maybe this
someone yeah God doesn't you're pulling
down on your problem such as nothing
more
Queen the six antium since it's
basically going on threatening be should
be seven and this is losing more
material I have I have this son this is
important and this is the end of the
game position I go here and it's
materially it's bad
I've got two pieces for the rook but
it's also that the bishops are so
dominating and okay I'll put the sack
here and you never move anything here
it's just sorry this is everything is
covered here and then I can easily
continue to to convert okay guys thanks
for watching